i know for all those of you who've lost
someone
21 years is both a lifetime
and no time at all
it's good to remember
these memories help us heal
but they can also open up the hurt
and take us back
to that moment
when the grief was so raw
that was president joe biden marking the
21st anniversary of the september 11th
attacks at the pentagon yesterday he
laid a wreath and vowed never to forget
the lives of those we lost and their
families yesterday as i mentioned 21
years since the attacks that killed
nearly 3 000 americans on u.s soil
the first lady attended a service in
shanksville pennsylvania while the vice
president was at the ceremony in new
york city
five defendants all held at the military
prison in guantanamo bay cuba were
formally charged in 2008 with helping to
plan the attack but their cases have
stalled over access to cia evidence and
recently over kova delays senior
investigative correspondent catherine
harris joins us now from the pentagon
with new developments on this uh
catherine good morning the the the
memory of 911 is strong but the search
for justice remains in terms of putting
people uh on trial and getting those
charges to stick where are we on that
front and good morning to you
good morning tony cbs news has confirmed
that military prosecutors and defense
attorneys are negotiating potential plea
deals that could take the death penalty
off the table for the five defendants
accused in the 9 11 attacks
he was living his dream pilot charles
burlingame was more than a war hero to
his family who affectionately called him
chick
before the anniversary his sister
deborah burlingame shared his story at
new york's 9 11 memorial he was really
our touchstone
and it was
he still is on 9 11 al qaeda terrorists
took over burlingame's american airlines
flight 77 slamming it into the pentagon
we didn't have remains for weeks we were
constantly saying to each other what
would chick want what would chick do
but her grief has turned to anger i was
outraged after learning a potential plea
deal is under discussion for the five
911 defendants held at this military
base in guantanamo bay cuba including
khalid sheikh muhammad the
self-described architect of 9 11. you're
in touch with other 9 11 families do
they feel the same way the families are
outraged and
they don't want closure they want
justice but another group september 11th
families for peaceful tomorrows believes
a plea deal could deliver some measure
of judicial finality all five defendants
and the government are all engaged in
good faith negotiations with the idea of
bringing this trial which has become a
forever trial to an end lawyer james
cannell's team represents 9 11 defendant
amar albalucci he's willing to plead
guilty to a substantial sentence at
guantanamo in exchange for a guarantee
of medical care and dropping the death
penalty before their transfer to
guantanamo bay in 2006 the five 911
defendants were held by the cia and
interrogated critics call the extreme
tactics torture the one that has had
perhaps the most lasting physical impact
was what they called walling alka
pradhan is a human rights attorney for
the 9 11 defense team he had told us
that his head was bashed against a wall
repeatedly until he saw sparks and
fainted nearly 3 000 people died on 9
11. is it right to take the death
penalty off the table the united states
government failed all of us
after september 11th
in their decisions to use illegal
techniques and illegal programs in doing
so irrevocably corrupted
any legal process that could have taken
place a spokesman for the military
trials did not answer our questions but
confirmed the parties are currently
engaged in preliminary plea negotiations
citing recent court filings i will not
have closure as long as there is any
possibility for some future president
to
commute their sentences or trade them
away charles chick burlingame was laid
to rest at arlington national cemetery i
do believe that forgiveness is more
powerful than love
but it's earned
they never will have that
if a plea deal goes ahead and the 9 11
defendants get lengthy sentences there
is a law in place that blocks their
transfer to u.s soil and federal custody
that means the guantanamo prison could
be open indefinitely tony
nearly 3 000 people dead here on u.s
soil on 9 11 and others continue to die
to this day from 9 11 related illnesses
and the search for justice continues
catherine thank you very much